vsauce kevin here with the game that
gives you quantifiable
verifiable strength against your
opponents
and even the advantage of going first
simple math and logic conspire to delude
you
into believing that the odds are in your
favor
but in the long run i'm gonna win
every time and even when you understand
how this paradox works you
still probably won't be able to
rationalize it
it goes like this i've got four
different dice and i've replaced their
regular sides of one through six
with different combinations of numbers
here are some maps to make it easier to
see a
has fours and zeros b has
all threes c has twos and sixes
and d has fives and ones you choose one
and i'll choose one
we roll and the highest number wins and
because i'm so nice i'm gonna let you
choose the best
die first which is the best
the simplest safest way to choose the
best one is to add up the sides and
take the highest total c has a total of
20.
those twos aren't great but the sixes
beat anything
c seems like the best overall choice
b and d each add to 18 and a only has
16 but if you choose c i'll choose
b and i'm gonna win most of the time
look here's a table of all the possible
roles both of us can have
of the 36 possible combinations of rolls
b
comes out on top 24 times to seize
12. you've chosen what looks like the
best die and i'll still beat you 2
out of 3 times ok so just adding up the
sides isn't good enough so
maybe you factor in standard deviation
on the sides
of the dice hold on hold on hold on
i'm gonna give you a game-changing hint
here it is a beats b b
beats c and c beats d these
charts account for every single role in
that progression
and i'm showing you the data to prove
that a
is at the top of a chain of dominance
you know that due to the transitive
property if a
beats b and b beats c then a should also
beat c
and if c beats d then a and b should
beat d
two it's like lining people up by height
if a is taller than b
and b is taller than c then a has to be
taller than c
makes sense right all right let's play
again and it sounds like you want to
choose
a this time because well it beats
everything
because i literally just showed you that
the transitive property makes a
better than b c and d right
wrong if you choose a i'm going to take
the worst choice at the very end of the
greater than
chain i'm choosing d to go against your
a
and i'm going to crush you with
my d how
before i explain i must tell you this
video is sponsored by me some make tools
for home improvement
we make tools for dome improvements
puzzles physics toys
experiments smart steam games exclusive
vsauce shirts
amazing science books and a lot more
with a curiosity curriculum to explain
the science and activities behind
it all the curiosity box is a seasonal
subscription box made by
us for you so to do some dome
improvement and add wrinkles to your
brain go to curiositybox.com
our 20th box is shipping right now click
the link below
let vsauce into your home
okay so here's why i'm choosing the
worst
die to beat your best
wait these dice are too easy
so many numbers repeat that it's
elementary and you're a genius
let's use another set of numbers from 0
to 12.
this set has the same property as the
easier ones a
is better than b b is better than c and
c is better than d
if we get a tie we'll just roll again
you choose a the strongest die
i want the weakest die because it's
actually not d is at the losing end of
our chain and my d
die is still going to win nearly
two-thirds of the time against
your strong a which seems
impossible but let's test it
so despite d seeming to be the weakest
and a being the strongest out of 15
rolls
d won exactly twice as many times as
a d is somehow stronger than
a in this game no matter what die
you choose i'm gonna beat you twice as
often as you beat me
even with the a is greater than b is
greater than c
is greater than d chain of dominance i'm
always gonna pick
a better die because these dice
aren't transitive these are efference
dice
here's the proof my voice cracked who
cares
math these charts reveal the truth about
the matchups in our zero through 12
dice and i've labeled the squares that
each die
wins just like i said a beats b around
two thirds of the time and it's the same
for
b versus c and c versus d but
let's look at d versus a despite being
worse against c which is worse than b
which is worse than a d is actually
stronger than a which makes
no sense it makes no sense but it's
mathematically true bradley efren is a
statistician who has won just about
every award in the statistics game
over the last 60 years and he's still
going
in 2018 he won the international prize
in statistics
which is basically the nobel prize of
stats and he invented what we now call
efference dice sets of dice that are
maddeningly non-transitive
and that non-transitivity is cloaked so
carefully that it's
almost impossible to grasp even when you
know it's true if you choose d
fine i'll just choose c which we know
beats
d most of the time if you choose b
i can choose a and win a lot more than i
lose
c i choose b a i choose d
you literally have no way to win this
game
in the long term because i can always
choose a die that's better than yours
even if you choose the best die
first and that's the vertical
paradox here how can you have the best
possible choice that
isn't how can a die prove it's the
strongest
and then lose to the weakest how can a
die
verifiably lose to everything except
when it's up against the one
that it shouldn't be able to win against
the problem isn't the dice
it's us we fall into a cognitive trap of
thinking in
absolute terms when real value is often
relative in this game the concept of
better or worse is deceptive
it depends completely on the situation
our brains especially when it comes to
numbers want to sort patterns and
construct algorithms and
employ heuristics that identify the best
choice and we love ranking things
whether it's
music or sports or serial tier lists
but life isn't always
transitive and if you get stuck thinking
in
absolutes you're gonna get duped by the
game master who knows
when the real value lies in the relative
they're gonna win most of the time
so unstick your brain and as always
thanks for watching i was gonna throw
these at the camera but
that would be bad so
[Music]
there
[Music]
you